how to do it better with GQ how to tuck  in your shirt the right way one start  with the right shirt signs of a - big  shirt it pulls out the sides of your  pants when you tuck it in like an upside  down chef's hat it's too large the  button on your sternum looks like it's  about to pop too small the hem doesn't  go down to your but that's what makes  sure that tuck it it'll stay tucked to  stuff your shirt tails into your pants a  tabloid three use the extra button on  the side of your trousers to keep your  shirt in place with the button closed  you'll be able to tuck your shirt as far  down as it goes reach through the fly to  maximize suckage perfecto  4 make that slightly to begi shirt a  little more slimmer usually look sharp  not like the sail on a boat there's any  to do it into the side of the fabric at  your side seams pull them out and fold  them back onto the rest of your shirt  looking good  you